and and
i'm disappointed that we already know
what the first two picks are going to be
and if if the first two picks aren't
trevor lawrence to the jaguars and zach
wilson to the jets
those will be the most stunning
developments in the history of the draft
because there's been no effort by either
team to push back against all the
momentum that's pointing toward lawrence
one wilson two the draft begins at three
and four the draft begins when we find
out whatever the 49ers have had up their
sleeve for the last month assuming they
know what they have up their sleeve and
there are some who say they still don't
know what they have up their sleeve and
then whatever the falcons plan it for
peter let's start with
the falcons at four because you and i
have spoken a lot about it you've
written about you had some great stuff
this week they've got options they've
almost got too many options because at
some point you got to choose an option
it's like let's make a deal you got to
pick one of those doors at some point
what do you think they're most likely to
do
draft a quarterback at four
take a guy like kyle pitts or trade out
of that spot
mike this is going to be an absolute
guess because
i give i give tremendous credit to the
falcons i really do
because they got two they got a
first-time head coach
they got a first-time gm
and those guys basically have kept a
very good lid on what they're going to
do
my gut feeling is
that if they get an offer that is even
representative that they will trade down
but that's all it is it's just a gut
feeling because i think
they look at their team right now and
and you know you ask yourself this
question
okay
if we pick
justin fields or trey lance or maybe mac
jones if he is not number three if we
pick one of those quarterbacks
then we're going to feel very good about
him to be our quarterback for the long
term
but
now we have to deal with matt ryan over
the next two years and this colossal
amount of money that he's owed and and
and so you know we still
have that thing about
we haven't really improved our team
for 2022
or 2021 and probably 22.
and
in my opinion if you're terry fontenot
and you're coming into this team
you see
holes on this team that you want to fix
and i believe that if they have an
opportunity to get a an extra one next
year by moving down a few spots and how
much is a few i don't know but if they
have that opportunity you ask me my gut
feeling what i think they're gonna do i
don't know what they're going to do and
that's the honest truth
but that is what my guess would be that
they would do and if they stay right
where they are
uh i would think they're gonna take kyle
pitts
and and you you make an excellent point
in that it's so critical to keep your
cards close to the vest and let no one
know what you're really thinking
because at the end of the day what you
have to do
is sell that pick to your fan base to
the media that covers your team and it's
so important to be able to say we got
the guy we wanted
and one way to make it clear that you
got the guy you wanted is to never say
who you wanted so then whoever you get
and look lying's a big part of the
football business and i think that it
blurs the line as to where lying is no
longer permissible but when it comes to
pr it wouldn't surprise me if a team
that didn't get the guy it wanted said
we got the guy we wanted and if you
don't tell anyone in advance who you
want it's plausible and the best case
scenario for the falcons peter would be
to trade down
and still get the guy they wanted if you
go down just a few spots step aside for
somebody to come get trey lance and
still get the guy you would have taken
if you put a name on the card at that
spot and you pick up
more draft capital that's a home run for
the falcons and whether it's true or not
they've preserved the ability if they do
trade down to claim hey that's the guy
we would have taken at number four
hey look you know if you look at where
this draft is right now okay
uh i don't think cincinnati is gonna
trade up to number four
i mean they're not okay
i don't believe miami is trading up to
number four
and i don't think detroit is trading up
to four i think if detroit goes anywhere
it's down
and then look at the next pick carolina
do you think that the first big move in
the history of uh the new atlanta
falcons uh
you know general manager and coach
that they want to hand
a quarterback to a division rival for
the next 15 years i doubt it
so to me
you know when you talk about trading
down to me that means one team
that means the denver broncos i can
envision the patriots
denuding the next two drafts to move
from 15 to four
i certainly can't imagine washington or
chicago at 19 or 20 moving up that many
and but i wouldn't be shocked if the
broncos did it
yeah i agree with you they're not happy
with drew locke new general manager and
george payton who's gonna have an idea
of who he wants at quarterback and locke
even though sims and i believed in him
tremendously not healthy enough not
consistent enough and at risk of being
bounced in favor of someone if they can
move up and get a guy like a lancer if a
justin fields would end up in their laps
all right you mentioned the bengals at
five they never trade up they never
trade down they never do anything that
makes it fun
and that's fine small c conservative are
the cincinnati bengals in many ways and
i think that everything points to penne
sewell i think it points so clearly to
sewell at five
that you have to
be aware of just the incremental risk
that somebody tries to get to four to
get sewell because i think it's bright
line bengals sewell at five am i wrong
um
well
i would have said a few days ago
no you're not wrong i think they're
going to take sewell i could still give
him sewell my mock draft comes out on
monday
that'll be
that'll be one of my final calls
but i think there's two things at play
here mike
number one is that the bengals have
always liked you wouldn't think of this
because mike brown is so conservative
the bengals have always really fancied
themselves an explosive offense you go
back to when i started covering the team
believe it or not in 1984 chris
collinsworth and david versor you know
you want at the time in the early 80s
everybody said why are they taking so
many receivers so high they got isaac
curtis that is what paul brown believed
he kind of passed it on to his son
so the only thing that i say in this
is that they saw
you know uh two years ago
at lsu
joe burrow
throw to jamar chase
for 1700 yards and 20 touchdowns
and they saw all this they've watched
all the tape and they've seen them make
beautiful music together there's no
question
that joe burrow has talked
up jamar chase inside that building
and and so all i'm saying is that
if i had to put a name down right now 8
11 a.m on friday april 23
i would put jamar chase
and add to that mike
there are probably
six
good second round tackle prospects
that the bengals could get
with their second pick in this draft so
i view them going right now wide
receiver tackle guard with their first
three picks
you mentioned collinsworth borough was
on colin's worst podcast earlier this
week and he was very diplomatic he was
very tactful yeah when speaking about
that pick and shireen williams picked up
on it because she said you know last
year you had kyler murray
stumping publicly for cd lamb to be
drafted by the arizona cardinals even
though they had just traded for deandre
hopkins but college teammate i got to
take a stand for my guy
she read it as
maybe he doesn't really want chase or he
would have said something maybe next
level is he said everything he needs to
say behind the scenes and he's made his
message clear
and there's no need to go public and say
i want jamar chase i want jamar chase
maybe he knows
maybe he knows if he really wants jamar
chase he's getting jamar chase i mean
he's the one who's not going to have the
benefit of penae sewell to keep him from
getting injured again if he wants chase
at a certain point if i'm duke tobin if
i'm mike brown if i'm anyone in that
organization this is the guy i'm
building around you want chase over
sewell all right let's make it work
mike i i hey i respect shireen greatly
but i would i would disagree with her in
this regard
you know we now
in the sports media have sort of known
joe burrow for maybe a year and a half
okay ever since he really started
getting great at lsu
all right
in that year and a half
has joe burrow ever said anything
ever has he said
anything
no
he is a
just the facts stay in my lane
that's not my job
i read what he said and i listened to
the collinsworth podcast
uh while i was taking a bike ride in
beautiful prospect park brooklyn the
other day and i listened to the podcast
and i thought it was so interesting
because
chris is so folksy and down homey and
everything and tried everything to get
him to loosen up
and man
that guy he doesn't loosen up very well
and that's but that's just who he is
this is my job i'm going to do my job
duke tobin you have a job to do i'm not
telling you how to do your job you pick
the players that you think are best for
the team
you know and
and so that is to me
that is who joe burrow is and i respect
that i don't need to have him
getting in somebody else's business i
honestly think that he views this as hey
duke tobin you do your job i'll do mine
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports